[Music]
hi
i am pamela pairo phd by geological
sciences from argentina
in this presentation i'm going to show
you how to create a multi-lingual
website using block down hugo and nearly
fight
first of all why do you need a personal
website
having a personal website is another way
to showcase your cv or resume with the
styles
and gives you the freedom to be creative
by writing posts
you will practice your communication
skills you can exchange
knowledge with colleagues and therefore
your networking will be expanded
in my experience when i came across with
difficulties or doubts i had able to
solve the issues
thanks to the posts shared by others and
finally the personal website
is a platform to connect with the world
for those of us who aren't
native english speakers it's fundamental
to have a multilingual website
in english to disseminate our work
through the global community
and in our native language to make our
website content more inclusive and
accessible for everyone
let's get started we began creating a
new
repo in our github account then in
rstudio create a new project with
contribution
and unload block down and hugo you can
look
at all the themes and select one on the
hugo website
after that you will have the default
version
of the site in the viewer panel so it's
time to customize
the main files that are part of the
website are showing here
in config tom is where it's located the
global setting for the site
and in config default folder are
the param storms where you can change
the color
team the font size of your website and
add
your contact details to change what
appears
in the navigation menu bar is necessary
to edit the menustone file
and in language term is where you can
change the language
setting and how to make your personal
website multilingual
i'm going to show you an example of the
bilingual website
english and spanish in the con in the
language term you have to uncomment the
lines
or a second language to configure your
website
here we have the information about the
english part for example
the language code where it's located the
content
and the title note that the abbreviation
of the languages are pretty financed so
if you want a portuguese website for
example you need to check
which is the correct abbreviation then
in each language will need their own
menustone5 and a subfolder
within the content folder finally choose
the default
a language that the visitors will see
when visit your
page and for make it visible that the
website is multilingual
check in paramster that show language
is true when you are done with your
edits and you are happy
with your website it's time to put it
online
one way to do this is using netlife
one of the advantages of deploying your
website through nedliver is that
allows you to have a static site for
free and easily
basically it connects to the remote
repository on github to deploy
every change that it makes on the
website it will be automatically
updated after to push to github
it's important that the hugo version
that you are
running locally might match with the
version that the
that netlifer is going to use to build
your site and how to do that
check the first the your local version
of hugo and pick up the nucleophile tomb
to your project raw directory and
specify the hugo version
then in go to the netlife webpage
and login within with with github
to select the repo you've been working
with block down
you will see something like this but
with your information
go to show advanced and just just in
case
write the hugo version and finally you
will have your
website in the latest version of
lockdown
you can set up the hugo version by
running this code
until tonightly file the hugo version
with this function if you want
more information here are some blogs
that i use in this presentation
and you can find me on my website and on
twitter
thank you
[Music]
you